- And he's like, ""I'm a
lizard!
Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah!"
And then he sprays acid
on his lizard tongue.
Guys, I don't know how many
hits
is in a spray of LSD.
He was already a lizard.
[upbeat music]
- How you doing, ladies?
Can I interest you in a...
threesome?
Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
I'm your host, Roy Wood Jr.
[gasps]
Huh.
'Sup, Little Roy?
- I did it again.
[suspenseful music]
♪ ♪
[goat bleats]
- Hello, Roy.
How's the water?
Does it feel...pure?
[dark electronic music]
Can you feel me
inside of you?
♪ ♪
[cheers and applause]
- You know him from his podcast
called "Here We Are."
Shane Mauss, everybody.
[cheers and applause]
- I'm an adrenaline junkie.
And when you're in adrenaline
junkie,
it's a weird addiction to have.
What you do is, you just do
things intentionally
that are so reckless that you
almost die,
and then when you don't die,
you're like,
"Yay, I didn't die."
That's...how you get your fix.
It's the only way to do it.
And I've got myself in some odd
situations.
Here is the time that--this is
probably the closest call
that I've ever had, and I do
want to say,
I do not blame LSD
for this story, all right?
Reckless young man.
LSD happened to be involved.
Not LSD's fault.
If you've never done LSD,
it's--first off,
I love psychedelics.
It's my least favorite.
It's just--it's, like, 10 to 14
hours.
Who has the time?
[laughter]
[laughs]
Hour three of an LSD trip, I'm
like,
"You mean I get to feel like
this
for eight more hours?"
[laughter]
Hour ten, I'm like, "Yeah, I
get it.
Whatever. Like...
"What do I got to go to sleep
to turn off these squirmies?
Like, what...this is just...
It's just boring."
[laughter]
So one drop--
it's usually on a sugar cube
or a piece of paper
as a hit; that's, like, you're
standard dose.
One hit and you remember how
amazing trees are.
You...you forgot.
[laughter]
You used to know.
When you were three years old,
you knew just how amazing trees
were.
You just got a little
too complacent with life.
Have a hit of LSD one day, hit
the old rest button,
and you're like, "Oh, damn, are
they breathing?
That's amazing."
[laughter]
That's one hit; two hits, the
trees remember
now amazing you are.
[laughter]
Three hits, that's kind of
getting into dangerous terr--
you do three hits of acid,
you're like, "Damn.
Now I've got to learn how to
paint."
[laughter]
"I have no natural artistic
abilities."
Four hits, you think you're a
wizard.
You start dressing like one.
You have no powers.
You're super annoying to
everybody.
And so this was in
my hometown
of La Crosse, Wisconsin,
on the border
of Minnesota and Iowa.
And I had two hits of acid,
and it--it was reasonable.
Here's what's not reasonable.
I went to a bar,
like a real divey,
drunkard bar.
You don't want to be around
a bunch of, like,
sloppy drunk people
when you're tripping.
Like, sloppy drunk people,
if they figure out
that you're tripping,
they'll always try
to mess with you
in this weird way of how
they think tripping works.
"Whoa, is this crazy?
"We're not even touching you.
Whoa!
Is that weird?"
"Oh, yeah,
that's weird all right.
"Yeah.
"You're gonna want
to stop doing that now.
You look like an idiot."
So we're trying--
me and my four other friends
also did two hits,
but we're all trying to keep it
on the down low so we don't
have to deal with that.
And what happened was,
my acid dealer's dealer
walked into the bar.
And this is like the guy
that makes LSD
for the state of Wisconsin
at the time.
And I recognized him.
He was a couple years
ahead of me in high school.
So I was like,
"Hey, Ryan, what's up, man?"
And he comes over
and he's like,
"I'm a lizard!
Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah!"
[laughter]
And I go, "Oh, dear.
Uh..."
I don't know
how many hits that is.
That's--
That's a lot.
Cover blown, I guess.
[laughter]
And we're panicking, 'cause we
just took two hits of LSD.
LSD takes, like, an hour to
kick in,
and you never know what any one
trip is gonna be like.
This is the problem with LSD
being illegal is,
it's on the--you know, it's on
the underground scene
of people--it takes a real
intense knowledge of chemistry
to make good LSD.
You can't just look up at
couple YouTube videos
and be like, "Oh, I'll just put
in some paprika,
'cause I don't have the other
thing."
Like, it doesn't--it just
doesn't work like that.
And so you never knew what any
one trip was gonna be like.
This dude made our acid.
He's a lizard now.
[laughter]
That's...
It's not at all the experience
we were looking for.
We--we were hoping for a little
bonding, you know,
and maybe some deep
conversations.
You don't want to be a reptile.
And, I mean, I get it.
You can get in some, like,
weird thought tunnels
when you're trip--it's one of
the side effects--
or one of the beautiful things
about psychedelics is--
one of the best lessons that
you can ever learn from them
is to question everything.
That's one of the most
important lessons in life,
is to question everything.
I know some of you are
skeptical.
You're like, "Question
everything?"
Now you're getting it,
but...
[laughter]
But, like, there's nothing
inherently wrong
with asking yourself, "Am I a
lizard?"
[laughter]
So long as immediately
afterwards you conclude,
"Nope, not a lizard.
That's a weird idea
"popped in my head.
"What was that about?
"Am I a giraffe?
"No, of course not, not a
giraffe.
"Am I a human?
Oh, yeah.
"I guess I am a human.
What does it mean to be
human?"
And then you jump down that
little rabbit hole,
and that's how you have a
successful trip.
Well, this poor fellow got
himself stuck in some
weird lizard universe.
We don't know how to get him
out of it.
And then he opens up
his jacket
and he pulls out this vial
of liquid acid.
Like, 200, 300 hits of liquid
acid.
And he starts unscrewing the
cap.
And he pulls out this big old
dropper
full of liquid acid.
And we're like, "Uh-oh."
[laughter]
Um...what are you doing
with that life sentence
in a public space?
[laughter]
- And he's like, ""I'm a
lizard!
Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-ah!"
And then he sprays acid
on his lizard tongue.
Guys, I don't know how many
hits
is in a spray of LSD.
He was already a lizard.
[laughter]
Then he dips back in for number
two.
We're like, "Ohhh-ohh-ohh,
hey, hey."
We got him to stop.
We were like, "No," we talked
him out of it.
He had just ordered beers.
We had four beers up on the
bar.
And so instead of spraying
another spray on his tongue,
he just sprayed
all of our beers with acid
and then crawled
out of the bar
like a lizard,
and we never saw him again.
[laughter]
In life, I mean.
[laughs]
Fun update to that story.
I actually--I did look him up
on Facebook
to if he's still alive or
whatever.
He is.
He's still alive and well.
He's actually in the military
now.
Yeah, you're gonna need some
structure in your life
after an experience like that.
Works out well for the
military as well.
We do a lot of stuff in the
Middle East.
We probably do need
reptile-like people
that are acclimated for those
temperatures.
[laughter]
But and we're all sitting there
looking at these beers like,
"Oh, my...how much acid was
that?
"That's, like--we already did
two.
"That's, like, really the
limit.
"What was that, like,
8, 20 hits in each beer?
"That was, like,
an insane amount.
We can't--no--we can't."
[laughter]
But you would hate to waste
that $1.50 draught beer.
Wouldn't you?
[laughter]
And we drank those beers,
we did,
and believe it or not,
we had a fantastic time.
It was--it was terrific.
At one point,
I put on some Rollerblades,
went to a skate park.
A lot of people
don't know this,
Rollerblading can in fact
be the second most painful
homosexual act.
[laughter]
The first of course,
burning in hell.
[laughter]
But...
It was--
it was going great.
There was, like,
a glowing red line
in front of everything
I needed to do,
and I was doing half-pipes.
And I'd never done anything.
It was amazing.
And I had such a great time.
We decided
we were gonna go
and see--
see a sunrise.
And we had--
we scooped up a designated
driver.
One of my friend's girlfriends
is gonna drive us up there.
And we walked, like, a mile to
my car.
We get to my car, and she's
like, "Oh, I can't drive stick.
I can't drive manual."
And I'm like, "Well, walked all
the way here.
"It has been eight hours.
I did just pull off
some Tony Hawk shit."
[laughter]
"I bet I'm okay to drive.
"I'll tell you what, why don't
you sit
"in the passenger seat,
navigate,
"tell me if I'm screwing up.
"If I am, I'll just pull over.
We'll call it there."
So that's the deal, so she gets
in the passenger seat,
and I'm driving.
Three tripping dudes
in the back,
and they're just
freaking out the whole--like,
"What are you drive--
Oh, this is crazy!
I can't believe you're--"
They made some solid points.
I'm gonna be honest.
[laughter]
But everything's going fine.
And then we took some weird
turn.
Like, I thought I knew where I
was going,
and then now I'm off in some
area
that I hadn't been to before.
And they had finally calmed
down in back,
but because they'd been giving
me such a hard time
and stressing me out, I thought
I'd get them back,
and how I decided to do that
was,
there was just this long
straightaway,
and I was, like, I'll just
floor it down
this straightaway.
It was like--it was one of
those hills--
I don't know if you've ever
been in, like,
the backcountry road where,
like, there's an incline
and then there's, like, a hill,
and you fly up,
and you got, "Whoo," and you
get a little thing in your--
your belly, a little
roller-coaster thing.
That's all I wanted.
And then we're gonna watch the
sunset.
So I'm, like, flying up this
hill.
And I'm going, like, 60, then
70,
like, 80 miles an hour up this
thing.
What I didn't see
was there's a sign
on the side of the road
that said,
"15 mile an hour turn ahead."
I--I just assumed
it kept going straight.
You know who saw that sign
is the three tripping dudes
in back.
They all saw that sign.
They tried to warn me
about that sign
via a series of screams.
But they had already
cried spirit wolf,
and I wasn't hearing it.
So this is just great.
They're screaming.
I'm sure showing them.
And I get up
to the top of this hill,
and I'm like, "Uh-oh.
Nothing after this."
I hit the brakes, too late.
Car's in the air.
Somehow I landed and I,
like, made this insane turn
and just Tokyo Drifted
around the--
Like, "Oh, I got it!"
And now, like, I'm trying
to straighten out my car,
and it's going all--
and I'm like,
"Where's that red line
when I need it?"
Almost had it,
and then the, uh,
back passenger tire
caught a little bit of gravel,
on the shoulder of the road,
which sent my car into a spin.
And then we all flew off
of a cliff
like a Frisbee,
and, uh--I don't know why
you're laughing
about this, guys.
And then we just dropped
straight down, like 50 feet
into a farm, just a cornfield.
Just straight down somehow.
I don't know how we didn't flip
over.
'Cause we definitely would have
been dead.
Landed.
All four tires exploded.
Both axles just snapped,
immediately, and I was like,
"Ohhhhh!
"That's what you guys
were screaming about?
Oh, I'm so sorry!"
[laughter]
Lost some friends that day.
Not--they're still alive.
They just won't talk to me
anymore.
And...everyone is fine.
And that is why
I rarely do acid.
Um, set and setting, everybody.
Set and setting.
Thank you very much.
- Shane Mauss.
[cheers and applause]